That was obviously the phenomenal Greg Kinnear
in his horror comedy show, almost hard to pin it down,
phenomenal tone, called "Shining Vale".
Yes.
Tell us about the show.
It's on Stars,
it just debuted on the 6th of March.
And it's comedy and it's horror,
and there's a mystery in it.
And it's this family in New York...
They've had this thing.
My wife, America's sweetheart Courtney Cox is--
Oh, we love her so much.
She's had an indiscretion.
(audience applauding)
Yep.
Imagine.
And we move out to the country,
I find a house $200,000 below asking, deep in Connecticut.
Gee, I wonder why.
I think, "Hey, here's a deal."
But we're in this freaky house.
I don't really see a lot of what's happening,
she's seeing things that I'm not seeing,
so I don't get to do a lot of the horror looks.
But I love the tone of this show,
because it is creepy and scary.
And then there's levitate.
You ever seen a ghost?
I don't think so.
I don't either.
I believe in everything.
But a lot of people have,
are you amazed at how many people have an experience
of having seen something,
or, believe they've seen something other worldly?
It sort of makes sense.
It's like UFOs and aliens, come on,
of course there are other life, there's other life.
And that's not just the E.T in me talking.
Right.
You would think that that was...
(audience applauding)
You're the only one who can say,
"That's not just the E.T in me talking."
No one else can say that Drew.
Listen toots, I'm not talking E.T here doll,
I'm saying as a citizen of the world
there's no way we're alone.
It's not possible.
So I'm open to everything.
You had me at toots.
Right?
I like to kick it old school.
Speaking of old school,
someone else that we worked with in common is Gary Marshall.
He's a lovely man.
He really was.
He was a lovely man.
Gary Marshall, he's so excited to talk to you,
and come on.
He always said toots.
Yeah, I'm sure he did, I'm sure he did.
Is it true that he had a weird food combo
that he really liked?
He would always be on set and he'd say,
"Get me my bananas and tuna fish."
(audience murmurs)
For real, and he would get the bananas and tuna fish,
it's his thing and it stayed with me my whole life.
And I have a feeling that something bad's happening.
Angel, thank you.
Oh, look how lovely they made these.
Thank you Angel.
Have you ever tried the banana,
the nana tuna?
I have not ever done this.
Nana tuna, should we try it in honor of Gary?
This is...
I know, I'm a little nervous.
(audience applauding)
Really?
I feel like I'm on "Fear Factor".
(laughs) Hey, I feel a new segment coming on.
All right.
(audience exclaiming)
Gary, I hope you're watching.
(audience applauding)
Eh.
Not as bad as I thought.
No.
I do think there's just a tiny bit of a sour cream
and a chive would also really up the game.
Yeah, I think this could be perfected.
I do too.
Okay.
(joyful music)